I heard this crazy story it's random and
I have to know if it's true did you
accidentally break a first lady's ankle
and how does that happen if
so well um George Bush invited me when I
was the chairman of the president's
Council of Fitness he would invite me
always to Camp David this was
1991 992 uh when he was president he
would invite me up there literally like
every month he loved hanging out with me
and working out with me we do throwing
Hors SHO and you know going running up
there and all the stuff and uh I was one
time up there in the winter and so he
said to me says I have this great sled
which was not really a sled it was a
thean yeah and and so with sleds you can
steer the sled with the with your feet
uh but that one I couldn't really steer
so we go down the hill in the snow there
he's sitting behind me and he says you
steer and I did not know how to steer so
so I mean it's just going fast and fast
and all of a sudden we approaching this
tree and all of a sudden Barbara comes
out behind the tree and then we just ran
into her leg and uh and so the poor
barabar Bush you know she was like she
had to go to the hospital afterwards she
had the you know a sprained leg and she
got a cast on it and the whole thing
like that but I have to say that they
were very gracious about it and the way
they they took it and uh you know I I
apologize I said I feel really bad
nobody has this story that's incredible
she was a wonderful first lady
[Music]
[Applause]
wow thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home